man it's your boy dax and make sure you
check me out on the bootleg kev podcast
yo bullet cat podcast special guest in
here my god dax welcome to the show man
man it's your boy dax and we back at it
like a bad habit if you want something
in this life you better go grab it and
today baby we about to make a big play
he totally just turned that [ __ ] right
on yes sir got to start off with my
affirmation we was very much talking and
then he just that [ __ ] just boom bam yes
sir it startled me
welcome man how you been doing man i'm
great man i'm great i'm really good yeah
uh you got this new record dear alcohol
that we just watched together yes sir
it's like country-ish
would you say it's country uh
you kind of sing with a bit of a country
accent you know it's crazy like that's
how i just sound when i'm like
normal tone singing
but um also just like places i've lived
i've been influenced by a lot wyoming
montana
shout out to um have you ever watched
yellowstone no it's based in my mind
what is that it's just a it's a tv show
with kevin costner it's basically it's
based in montana okay you play
basketball in montana missoula montana
university of montana big sky conference
big sky so you played there and wyoming
i played at casper college in casper
wyoming i played at the university of
montana in missoula montana and i played
at newman university in wichita kansas i
was gonna say i thought you played in
wichita too yeah yeah three schools and
four and a half years
damn transfer bug bit me what was that
like if you're playing basketball
because those are obviously
was missoula the biggest college you
played at yeah that was d1 because
that's big sky conference
so you ended up there at the end
no i i got there finally achieved my
goal of getting division one basketball
then wanted to do three years there
because i was a sophomore
and then there was a coaching change
tinker went to oregon state uh travis
the cure came in from cal and then it
just didn't work out whole new coaching
staff i got hurt at one point came back
then they asked me to transfer what did
you play combo guard like one and two so
kind of i was a scorer like monta ellis
yeah i was a scorer for sure i was a
sniper you know you'd be you're like
jamal crawford
no no no no no no jamal crawford's a
combo guard maybe he's a combo guard but
he's like six eight yeah but like i'm
six two you know but he's a scorer yeah
he's like a mercenary goats man
dion waiters
crazy amazing player as well i would
compare
more like a jay hard
okay but with you know you look like you
you look like james harden right that's
why i said that yeah yeah okay right i
was a mixture of people okay but the
mamba mentality cause he's always been
my favorite player has anyone ever said
you look like james harder in a bit i've
i've gotten it quite a bit i see it in
the eyes yeah yeah shout out to james
guys see right through you
um so what's been going on man i mean
obviously you've kind of turned into one
of the biggest independent artists
period on the hip-hop side hey man thank
you um
what i appreciate about what you do is
like i feel like you very much do your
thing and kind of drown out whatever
else is happening in the world right you
have your your what you do you
yeah i was just saying you treat your
records um and videos like their albums
yeah um
but you know it's been a long journey
and i feel like now i mean you're
bigger than you've ever been um
how do you feel about like where things
are now man
um i feel great and i like what you said
about i always just focus on what i'm
doing i have a big thing where it's like
you just [ __ ] with the people who [ __ ]
with you right you know and i make sure
i always try to
make an emphasis that i spend my time
building with people who want to build
with me and instead of arguing with
those who don't
so i just stay out of everything you
know and just focus on the people who
are giving me their ears and their
energy and allowing me to create the
soundtrack to their life so i feel good
um
it's a lot of good things going on
there's a lot of impact being made and
it's all within the positive space of
how i want it to be so it's like i'm
receiving the same energy i'm putting
out so
i'm yeah good spot i think like uh
what you just said you know most artists
are so worried about
the people who have negative [ __ ] to say
right or the people who are like
well you know you you should be doing
this or ah this is that or this is corny
whatever as opposed to focusing on like
the people who really [ __ ] with what
you're doing and just doing more of that
and growing that out as opposed to
worrying about like those people
probably weren't going to [ __ ] with you
anyway exactly i've always been like
they used to call me an aloof i don't
ever heard of an aloof where it's just
like i've heard that word yeah i don't
know what the [ __ ] it means i've just
always been in my own world
yeah you're not providing positive
energy in that world you get absolutely
no energy from me i feel like you're
very i wouldn't say anti-industry but
you're here despite not being quote
unquote an industry guy if that makes
sense right yeah i don't know like
anyone within it or i never had any ties
to it so it's just like i don't even
look at it like i try not even to even
use that word i just look at it i'm a
i'm a business you're a byproduct of
what you do and right yeah no you you
like you said you have your business
model right
and it works yeah so yeah i feel like
the first time i met you was like
maybe 2017 or 18
yeah it was when you had the first time
i came out to
california or second time i feel like
you were managed by the dude with pink
hair now who sings uh
the photo guy what's his name
he was with you i don't know if he
managed you uh that was nathan yeah yeah
yeah yeah um
that's and by the way totally
side interesting that guy's like making
music now that's awesome yeah he didn't
he didn't make music back then but
that's dope man i'm happy for him um
but yeah no it's been crazy because like
i feel like you have uh kind of amassed
this like family
um thing with your fans where you know
very much like what you do is like make
sure like all your fans feel
connected to you and you know i feel
like more artists should do that because
you know word of mouth is probably the
number one source of promotion and if
you have like this group of fans that
feel like they're a part of something
they're going to tell their friends
right and me a big thing like i don't
even like the word fan like i call it
fam like supporters i like i hate
it's weird i just don't like that word
you know what i mean and i just sort of
live like that so it's like
my goal is to always provide more value
than they're providing me like i'm
trying to over deliver you know so i
think it's like the people that that
[ __ ] with me they feel like they're
gaining something out of
you know
being along with the journey
how important has it been for you to um
focus so because you know i feel like
uh
sometimes artists make the mistake of
like spreading themselves too thin on so
many different
platforms all your music is on spotify
right you have
tons of listeners on spotify but i feel
like you really double down on youtube
right and like building a community on
youtube yeah my first thing i said to
myself was you know you got to do more
than you're paid for and eventually
you'll be paid for more than you do so
youtube for me was actually the last
thing i focused on because it was the
one platform that was providing like a
monetary gain so i started off with
instagram and facebook in the very
beginning i was like okay let me just
see if i can
find like-minded people who are going to
enjoy at that time was my spoken word
poetry so you know i used to you know
follow all these things like button
poetry and all these other poetry pages
and just like people who engage with
that type of content right when i would
drop my poems and my motivational
speeches i would hit them up and be like
hey if you like this or it affected you
in any type of way could you share it
with two people and once i gained you
know a group of people who like that on
those two platforms where everything was
completely like free even though
youtube's not like i'm not people aren't
paying right but i gained money off
there yeah you can i mean at the time
you couldn't really monetize facebook
now you can but right back then you
couldn't right so i told myself okay
once i hit
a hundred thousand followers on
instagram that was when i was going to
transition and now putting my
videos
on youtube
so this was was this technically before
you were making music or was this right
in the beginning yeah this was this was
uh i dropped my first song september 1st
2016. so this was march
april 2016 when i started the poetry
stuff and that was like a six month
period wow yeah that's crazy man and for
people who don't know another part of
your story that i that you allude to a
lot is like you you were a janitor right
a lot of people know that but you know
what i mean i know that yeah i was an
overnight janitor so once i
lost my division one scholarship went to
d2 it was a smaller school private
catholic school like you know there was
like 800 people living on campus
um i needed money so i became an
overnight janitor on campus and i did
that for about two and a half years
and while you were doing the janitor
thing were you this is when you were
like also doing the poetry thing was it
kind of like where they said
in the beginning in the beginning it was
just like i was doing my janitor job in
the poetry department it was called day
matthias hall which was attached to
where we played
basketball got you so it's like i was
still in school still playing basketball
doing all that stuff but i always say
like i was around all these poetry
events so much and all these other
things that i don't know if maybe that
had an influence on me
and then one day uh we went to go play
arkansas fort smith and on the bus i
wrote my first poem wow and i looked at
it and i was like wow i think this is
what i'm supposed to be doing for the
rest of my life
what about like uh you know coming from
because you're from ottawa yeah which is
in canada i don't know if a lot of
people know that you're canadian
you're not like gangbanging canada like
that all the time i think you're [ __ ]
i throw it up your fans know yeah 613
ottawa 613 right is it the six or is the
i think that's toronto the six is
toronto
also the sixth one sixth yeah
i think i think we say the third though
but like i i left
ottawa when i was 18 i wasn't even
making music at all so it was like my
connection to like the ottawa music is
now building is your family still out
there uh we're scattered
so like how did you grow up did you grow
up with both parents or what you're like
um so i was born in newfoundland then we
moved to ottawa um my dad's been working
in the u.s
for a while since i was like six maybe
so it was like he would come back
got you a couple times so your dad would
work in the states and then come back a
couple times a year got you so your pops
is in the states yeah nice that's what's
what about your mom your mom saw it
there she's in canada shout out to
canada do you go back often i do man
honestly i i'm i'm
rarely even coming to california as much
anymore unless i'm filming music videos
but i like to just like i'll go to
montana
and just like chill in a hotel or i'll
go back to kansas basically wherever
like i have roots i just like to like
circulate so i can have this continuous
feeling of
reality that's real right that's some
real [ __ ] yeah la's a weird place like i
feel like
you know
uh it's very easy to get wrapped up into
the la [ __ ] and by la [ __ ] i don't how
about this
i don't even mean la [ __ ] i mean just
the music industry that is here in la
right what comes along with that a lot
of people who move out here you know
being in the valley whatever it is
um
how did you how did you feel like you
haven't gotten wrapped up because i feel
like the only time you really got
wrapped up in some like
rapper [ __ ] was like whatever happened
with tory lanez uh which was what that
was like three or four years ago yeah
that was a while ago but like um how did
you like
you've managed to kind of
i guess uh avoid a lot of that the stuff
that i see so many artists go through
when they come to la like i feel like
you're every time i see you you're by
yourself like you're very low-key or
very
you know you're very much like
like we talked earlier you're just kind
of
on an island yeah
that's just how i've always been you
know even my mom's like that like
she'll just be in like one spot i'll be
like mom are you bored like no danny i'm
just here i'm just praying i'm just
happy you know i'm very much like that
too very simple um we gotta stop the
interview real quick man shout out to
our sponsors at blue chew the good thing
about blue chew not only does it make
that dick [ __ ]
you know what i mean
get that thing swinging like it never
swung before
but what i love about blue chew is
it's all online man you know usually
when you want to go and get some of that
uh you know some of that good good some
of that blue juice maybe some viagra
first of all it's got the same exact
active ingredients as viagra and as
cialis but you don't have to go into the
doctor's office to get it all right all
you got to do is go to bluetooth.com you
have an online consultation and then
they discreetly
send it to you and it's also discrete
villain you know what i'm saying
it's crazy let me tell you something
maybe you got a first date you want to
make sure you blow them back out that
day you know what i'm saying
pop that blue chew it's a chewable form
some people don't like swallowing pills
ladies are going to love to swallow you
though once you're on that blue chew
i'll tell you that much bud for sure so
what you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com
use the promo code bootleg and you're
going to get a month supply of bluechew
for free all right you're going to thank
me later for this but i would say
um
that i forgot the question what was the
[ __ ] question how did you just
avoid like kind of some of the pitfalls
people fall into coming and chasing the
industry in l.a um i would say it's
because like i said my goal was never to
make music so it's like i didn't grow up
wanting
to be a rapper be a rapper right you
know what i mean and even when before i
started rapping you know i don't even
like i consider myself an artist but
right um
it started with poetry and motivational
speaking
because when i first started i was like
i don't know if i can fit into this
because i don't think i'm really of the
lifestyle that i see is most portrayed
which is why for me poetry was the
natural right
and then even once i started rapping i
was like how am i going to co-exist
within this space
when i don't really fit into what the
norm is then i figured out a way to
merge my poetry and make music with it
so it's like it's never been my goal to
you know
i don't know whatever the
i guess and la's a thing where it's like
i tell people all the time when you come
to l.a it'll trick you because you're so
close yet so far i remember like my
first parties like i go to the parties
and i'm like yo that's yeah yo that's yo
that's
and you get like people's numbers and
it's all dope and then like once you
wake up and you're no longer drunk like
no one replies and like you're far as
hell away such a real estate so i had an
eight like month period when i first
came here i was going to a bunch of
events yeah i was drinking every night i
was at the parties i was trying to get
it in you know i just finished college
basketball you know i was doing my thing
yeah you know what i mean but i just
sort of
i found myself and i was like man the
person who's gonna change my life is the
person in the mirror yeah
yeah man i always tell everybody don't
like if you worry so much about the
things that you can't control you're
gonna drive yourself crazy right if you
focus everything in like the things that
you have
control over
you should be all right right that was a
big thing for me in 2022 focus on what i
can control
so yeah you have had a bunch of like i
wouldn't say a bunch but i feel like you
have had a plethora of uh haters in the
hip-hop world i don't think so well i've
had like artists who did you have um i
don't know if you even there was an
artist who came on my show that i don't
even want to know i don't even want to
go i don't even know who i was all right
um it was like i i don't know i don't i
can't even remember who it was yeah um
i think it was another youtube guy okay
um and i don't even distinct you as a
youtube guy but thank you um but nothing
wrong with that the tory lanez thing
what happened there
are you asking me the story yeah what
years later give us give us that
i've talked about that story so much all
i would say at the end of the day was a
misunderstanding honestly
tory lane has always been one of my
favorite artists growing up from canada
right and i think it was just a
misunderstanding it was me like i said
it was my first or second year in the
music industry and one thing i learned
from the situation that i do want to say
to all men out there is that regardless
of who was right or wrong you know
something whatever energy you put out
into the world sometimes it comes back
to you yeah that's one thing i learned
and grew as a man from that situation
and to me i have nothing but love for
the man i think you know
i'm i'm thankful that everything turned
out well
and i'm able to speak about it that is
real though sometimes like uh
the energy like you said man if you're
moving a certain way some some
sometimes it just
you might not even connect the dots
right so
now i grew i grew from the situation and
um i could go back i would you know i
probably i wouldn't even drop the diss
track i think it was i never want to use
my words to tear anyone down again and i
learned and i'm grown i'm happy that's
fair um
you recently did a record with trippy in
a video with trippy which was i don't
wanna decide yet big deal big dope video
too um
what like that's somebody who you know
is obviously a superstar in his own
right um how did that happen
um that was actually like a three year
process it was crazy it was like i made
i was actually in the studio when um
i'm looking up because i gotta look into
my brain to find this uh i was in the
studio when him and juice world made
that song that goes uh damn anything
with the bare bearing on right
now so you're in the studio with him in
juice world yeah there was a bunch of
people there okay that was like you know
back in the days when i was like first
out here and just like going to a bunch
of things so that was a cool moment met
them there and then i opened up um for
juice world in santa ana at a show which
was dope um
so i knew him from there
and then i put out she cheated again i
had that song next tried to get him on
this song and i saw him at uh rolling
loud
another year went by finally got him on
the song then another year went by
finally got the video done so it was
like a three year
is it like that much harder even though
you know somebody but when they're like
trippy red and there's label red tape
and you're an independent artist who's
just doing this [ __ ] is it is it does is
that why there's a delay because it's so
hard to get a record clear like that
um yeah and then just dealing with you
know like you know two grown men on
different schedules yeah things
connecting you know wanting to like you
know be there when it's made or then
wanting the video to you know get the
best out of someone yeah because i'm
sure you could have like gotten the
video done if you would have just sent
like a videographer to him right there
was a chance to do that as well but you
know i'll just wait yeah because you
your videos are very uh they're
they're they're crazy thank you you got
some of the best videos in the game man
wow that's love thank you no i feel like
your videos are very much um
like when you come up with a
give me your like timeline so you come
up with an idea for a song right you
record the song well i don't know i
never come up with an idea for a song i
hear the beat and then whatever starts
so that's where okay so so you beat will
play and i'll like get my first words
out and then depending on what those
first words are all determined in the
importance of that song for example dear
alcohol lex played the beat and i was
like i got wasted because i didn't want
to deal with myself tonight and then
once i said that i was like wow this is
an important one so i want to take my
time and make sure this is written well
so how yeah you finish the song then
does the video idea come in right away
or do you start plotting that now once i
finish the song i decide like a name
because i was gonna originally call the
song i got wasted and i was like i don't
think so but then i remembered that i
had made a poem called dear alcohol six
years ago that was one of my first poems
i ever wrote it was called deer alcohol
so i was like wow i think this is the
song that was supposed to go with that
poem
and then after i made that i was like
okay now the video
so it's like it goes beat
lyrics
song name
you can now put a video to it
and then just bring in the vision to
life right visually what is your uh
what's the most expensive video you've
done
um
because you've got some pretty
outlandish videos where i'm like [ __ ]
yeah uh
uh
um
i don't even know i shot so many videos
i shot like 30 something videos last
year only put out like 20 of them 24.
they're i work i work with people who
really help me not make them too
expensive like at the team like you know
whether i work with moses israel or i
work with logan mice it's like
i've been working with them so long that
they like know i'm on an independent
budget so we like are able to right
right right like a video like don't be
like oh is that a hundred thousand
dollars when it's really it was like
maybe like 18 to 25 right because we cut
all these corners and you know what i
mean so
i'd probably say like 25. that's not bad
um
you're still very much
like kind of because i think some
artists might not understand the
importance of doing like
if you're like a rapper
i think that i've seen so many artists
catch a break by jumping on old older
beats like you i feel like some of your
biggest youtube videos are
freestyles or yeah back in the day i'm
happy now that all my biggest videos are
singles but there was a time when yeah a
lot of my bigger videos were like you do
the rap guys yes i had the kill shot
remix i had obviously my tupac remixes
went crazy yeah um
so yeah but you'll still do those like
is that because like your fans love
those so you're like yo i got to do
these for the fans to me that's more
just like sharpening and getting better
at the skill right of
rap i feel like it's like my obligation
to like continue to improve myself and
get better so i like to challenge myself
and either hop on like a legendary beats
and try to see what i can do or just
you know like you got to put these words
together yeah you gotta challenge
yourself with the bars and have fun with
it so um do you feel like you've gotten
like like you know i feel like every
every you know you haven't been making
music that long yes but five now five
years it's pretty crazy and
you know
i've heard the improvement in you as
like just as an emcee
um do you feel like you know like
sometimes when you go back and listen to
some of your older [ __ ] is it like
because you're obviously better now than
you were then right i know sometimes
artists hate to listen to old [ __ ]
because because because of that like do
you ever go back and listen to old [ __ ]
and be like damn
um i i listen to ocean very very rarely
do i listen to old stuff but i'm not
gonna lie like i came in pretty good you
know like i was remixing the the like
hit him up and that was my first year
rapping and it's like i know if i went
back now i could put better bars on it
for sure right but it wasn't like i was
i was storytelling where i was at at the
point in time so it's like i don't think
i can even
you know um
are you like it feels like you're not
the album type of guy
oh i am
see but i just refuse to
i like i draw my first album paint
paints paintings i think it's a
masterpiece i love it to me you know and
um
it's like when you're independent
and you make music like i make like i
don't make throwaway songs right you
know like every single song
not even like i don't choose that's just
how my brain works is every single song
is has a meaning
it's boom boom boom boom boom so like i
consider my album like 14 single songs
maybe besides one or two yeah if you
throw an album out right there's going
to be
song i mean
you could probably in theory put an
album out and have every single song
have a video right and that's like
that's why my paint paints paintings out
by making a music video for every song
probably more effective to do it the way
you're doing it though in terms of just
like
the attention
right if you if you i mean it depends if
you believe in each of your songs i
would make a video from like i'm making
a video for each song because i believe
in each song that much and i believe
each song deserves a video that's some
good [ __ ] it's just like i like i really
do like my goal every year is to go
broke shooting videos
that's my goal
so you
reinvest all the money that's coming all
of it but i'm also lucky to just be like
you know i was born on a rock in
newfoundland like i'm not a
materialistic guy so like i'm lucky to
not want anything
i'm fine with the way i'm living and
so i just like i like to make videos i
like so the money that comes in goes
right back out yeah all of it that's the
mr beast mentality mr i just want you
know mr b says yeah yeah yeah i just
watched a youtube video uh an interview
with him he was um
talking about like he's like all the
money i make
i just
they go back into the video i'm just
like i just i just shot three music
videos and then like you know i'm paying
for those and then i'll make another
song and i gotta say i'm trying to shoot
a music video for every song in the
album and then i'm trying to make this
movie you're making a movie i'm making a
movie oh watching a movie for my album
you i feel like you you i mean you'd be
acting your ass off and right
these videos they do get pretty
intricate oh they get very intricate
yeah the joker [ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy
thank you thank you thank you yeah it's
like that was fun for sure [ __ ] wild
[ __ ] you'd be doing in some of these
videos yeah it's definitely jesus [ __ ]
all kinds of [ __ ] it's christ himself
god is good are you uh uh obviously
you're a christian guy yeah i'm i grew
up christian and all that stuff um i i
don't
i'm definitely a christian but i don't
like i'm not big on religion
growing up my mom took us to catholic
church okay uh i mean christian catholic
boom boom you know anglican
you know the jamaicans down the street
my boys they were you know seven days
adventist so like my mom would let me go
do that like as long as the connection
with god was there she would let you it
was cool you know so it's like
it's so
i try not to stress too much the
relationship between me myself and a
religion and try to stress more of the
relationship between me and god one of
my goals for 2022 though was go to
church more hmm so
was the last time you went to church
uh about
december december december and november
out here
um i think i was i was out here i went
to a place called church home hmm
there's some weird trick i've drive by
this place in uh hollywood it's called
mosaic and i always thought it was like
a museum because it looked like some
like fly like wow
fly like hipster museum and i just found
out like three days ago it was a church
and i was like what that makes sense
they got they got they got churches out
here like liquor stores
on every corner it's big business yeah
oh man big business
yo we got to stop the interview real
quick shout out to our presenting
sponsor odd socks baby hey man listen
all i keep on my ass is odd socks draws
all i keep on my feet uh socks you know
why cuz they're the most comfortable
socks in the world and i'm not just
saying this because they promote the
podcast i'm telling you the socks are
crazy uh they got all the licenses look
they got halloween socks they have back
to the future socks
they got [ __ ] twizzler socks old
dirty bastard socks r.i.p to odb all
right they also got their draws if you
want to wear some underwear with pizza
on them whatever you need but my
favorite are the odd socks basics baby
these are just the plain boys
these to me are the most comfortable
socks in the world all right
so trust me when i say go to
oddssoxofficial.com
thank me later when you go to check out
buying the most comfortable socks in the
world
get some wwe socks too i just saw a
sneak peek of the new wwe line and
they're [ __ ] insane
in [ __ ] sane uh go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg kev that's one word together
bootleg kev
we should talk to them about shortening
that bootleg cab is the promo code you
will get twenty percent off at checkout
one more time go to ostoxofficial.com
save 20 off using that promo code
bootleg kev let's get back to the
interview what are some things you
learned obviously uh touring with tech
nine and uh man you know his his tour uh
is an interesting uh amazing there's
rules there's a handbook see it was easy
for me yeah cause you ain't with none of
that [ __ ] [ __ ] right no i've never done
any drugs well i know people who have
gone on tour with tech9 and like
absolutely hated it got fined got kicked
off oh wow mgk [ __ ] hated it oh wow
uh freddie gibbs hated it a lot of
people hated it that was right at home i
mean you're like this is great yeah i'm
military man i'm doing you know 500 to a
thousand push-ups a day drinking eight
bottles of water like i don't do any
drugs i drink right you know i mean not
right now but i did then um that was
actually the tour that was crazy 55 that
was my first year of touring i did 100
shows that year wow the tec-9 tour then
my own tour america and my own tour
canadian and i went to the uk and did
shows too that's crazy that was the year
that really like
got me into the drinking habit and then
the pandemic happened right after i got
off when you're on the road i feel like
drinking is like a probably
readily available it's like the thing i
do to pass time and that first tour you
know i had to get the first tour jitters
out you know what i mean so i was
drinking before the show after the show
you know he was getting you know
so you're sober at the moment yes i
haven't been drinking now i was 30 days
on march 23rd i'm trying not to do the
counting thing too much though because i
already count the hell of [ __ ] and i'm
the type of guy who counts my steps you
know so it's like
i'm trying not to count
is it like a thing with alcohol where
you're like i got a serious problem or
it's like you listen i could drink and
be fine but i'd rather not
with me the way my brain works is i
don't know because i'm still such a
functioning person like i was the type
of person where i was like you can even
like ask the people on the tech nine
tour i would take like shots tequila and
do like 500 to a thousand push-ups
before the show right that's just the
type of person i am like drinking could
be like
i'll you know take a shot at tequila and
send a thousand emails
so it never got in the way of what i was
doing so if even when my mom was like ah
my mom was like when i went back home to
canada and i was like oh you gotta
you gotta stop drinking she calls it the
the dark drink she's from nigeria the
what drink the dark the dark the dark
the dark drink was that your uh were you
were you a doc were you a dark licorice
nah nah the tech nine tour taught me
that i should only drink tequila
if and when
yeah dark liquor is different man right
give me vodka give me tequila spirits
that dark liquor though starts kicking
in is when violence happens right but
that's like i said for me with my like
work ethic and everything it was hard
for me to be like i think this is too
much right right so what did you learn
from the tour though like tech nine and
just the whole strange i'm surprised
that did travis try to sign you i'm
surprised that he hadn't like we talked
about different things yeah and then
they they also had a dish they got the
distribution company they launched yeah
so
but um
it was a great tour man i learned a lot
obviously tech nine is one of the goats
point bank period you and that video you
guys did was crazy oh came through
faster you know there was like [ __ ]
all kinds of fighting and choreography
oh that [ __ ] was crazy we did that in
kansas city it's like [ __ ] blade man
it's amazing
yeah we did that in kansas city and um
the best thing
is to be able to learn
from the greats at the end of the day
that's you want to crash course
in music touring performing i mean you
go on tour with tech nine it's gonna
heighten your skill was this uh
was christo on the tour yeah yeah losing
my voice
those two guys together special
man the the [ __ ] the coordination the
choreography the way that
all right [ __ ] it's crazy that [ __ ]
popping and locking and [ __ ] that was a
great time
um
that was a great time yeah no tech is my
in my opinion the greatest uh and listen
i saw tech
the tour that he was alone
this was the recent one no there was a
tour before that where he didn't have
chris
where he was um coming out as like three
characters throughout the tour i think
he's the greatest performer in hip-hop
history just because i've seen him for
like 20 years do this [ __ ] and like
yeah
what he does
it's a different it's definitely like a
different level it's a different level i
agree with you but back in the day when
it was him chris calico
and i've god dammit how am i not
remembering the third dude's name
jesus christ i know the guy very well
there was the third guy
i need you to google that because i'm i
feel terrible because i know this
[ __ ] guy
oh there was they they call themselves
the unholy trinity wow i didn't know
that well i mean that was kind of like
not like official
um don't google the unholy trinity
because it's not going to come up but
that's just what
it was um
chris calico tech9 and
cali baby
what's the other guy
i have to have to get this right
because i know this guy
and i'm excited to hear because i didn't
know i feel terrible
so it used to be three of them doing
like dancing and like
um i'll just look at one of his old
albums that that guy's on but it was
like the craziest [ __ ] i've ever seen
like
like that [ __ ] was
wild right
chris calico okay we know that guy ah
jesus christ
it's gotta be on the tech nine collabs
album
i feel terrible for not remembering this
by the way
no no no
king ice was on the rock song
[Music]
i got to get it right man
tech nine collabs it's got to be on one
of these
the gates are mixed plate
crack calhoun [ __ ] calhoun god damn
it a bunch yeah how did i not sorry cut
i got cuts and [ __ ] number on my
phone
jesus christ calhoun brain fart that was
crazy those three guys
peak like 0809 [ __ ] wild man 0809 wow
those are good times man shout out to
tech yeah nah it's it's crazy because
like most people don't approach tour the
way the strange music approaches uh
their tours it's like a business it's
like hey we're we're on the like oh
we're liable for all the [ __ ] that's
happening on our tour right so i think
like every single rule that
um is in their rule book is because
something has happened
there's a reason why that rule's there
yeah exactly that's what they were
saying like you can't crowd surf right
because
something happened right you know you
can't have girls on the bus because
something happened right i mean [ __ ]
like that so yeah yeah that was super
easy for me to adapt i was like i bet
are you big on like the merch [ __ ] do
you sell a lot of merch i rarely
advertise my merch to be honest um i
don't know i've always just had a
problem asking people for money
i don't know why but i you know it's
crazy i went on my website the other day
some stuff was sold out so i felt good
yeah man you should ask people for money
man your your business yeah i know but
um no people buy stuff and i have it
attached on the bottom of my youtube now
they can do a thing where they put it on
your youtube got you so now it's like
all my videos it's right in there so
that's why they could click right a lot
of things are like selling out now
because it's it's fine it just shows up
there i don't gotta say it yo we gotta
stop the interview real quick tell us
about uh i'm gonna tell you about our
partners in my bookie man make sure you
go to mybookie.ag right now
it's gambling season nba playoffs are
about to start what are we doing you can
still get your futures in on the mvp
vote as well you can bet on everything
in my bookie man so look what you got to
do is go to mybookie.com right now
just go to my bookie use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account this is important when you sign
up for a new account use that promo code
bootleg and they will give you a deposit
match free money up to a thousand
dollars so if you sign up and you put
200 bucks in they're gonna give you
another 200 to bet with
thousand they're gonna give you another
thousand to bet with let's go for the
suns all the way just throw all your
money on the phoenix suns
all right and then bet that the warriors
won't make it out of the first [ __ ]
round because yokish is gonna [ __ ]
pound them in their ass probably great
odds on that one anyway
my bookie.ag my bookie just [ __ ]
google the [ __ ] my bookie use the promo
code bootleg and they will match your
deposit free money free money up to a
thousand dollars let's get back to the
interview with trail um
like what are the things that you've
cause i feel like uh you know you say
you you reinvest everything into the
videos right um but at some point in
time you have to like you know
i don't know upgrade things in life you
you wanna
at what point in time do you start
taking some money and putting it putting
it to this i'm sure you might be already
doing that to the next side yeah like
you want to
you might not be rapping in 10 years you
want to have
some sort of what i mean
music is the great i think music's a
better investment than because no matter
what it's going to always be creating
money yeah right your catalog's always
going to right every month and i own it
so you're just going straight
let's just run this catalog up yeah what
would make you sign like is there any
situation where you can see yourself
signing a major record deal um if they
can help me spread my message to the
world without me having to compromise
any of like you know what i want to
create when i want to drop it
um
and just anything that
deviates or goes outside of my moral
compass not saying i'm i don't even
believe in all the hubbub
i don't i don't prescribe to any of that
i just think but you still have to it's
a business deal and there's going to be
things within that deal that you have to
follow so if it like i need it to be
you need to have creative control and
yeah not for sure and then i think
owning your masters is like the one
thing artists
always [ __ ] off because they look at
that dollar amount that a label ass
offers them and then they're like here
take it give me the give me the million
dollars
so yeah i would love i would you know if
it can it just has to be right have you
been close ever
um
no
i've it was like like when she cheated
again and all these songs are blowing up
and even now i still visit a bunch but
it's like with the state and place i'm
at it's sort of like people are asking
well what do you want to do
yeah no no yeah dude you don't really
know honestly you don't i mean they
might hire you to help them with their
artists locations they'd be telling me
we'd be telling our artists to watch
what you do yeah and stuff like that so
it's humbling it's nice uh now that
we're kind of out of the pandemic-ish uh
are you gonna be going out back out on
the road at all yeah uh i'm gonna do a
canadian tour i think this year i think
i'm going to
the uk
i think i'm going to africa to um
scotland ireland scotland uh switzerland
fire some dope places do you still do
the thing where you like dm your fans
and tell them like yo share this with
two people type [ __ ] i i dm every day
i'm always replying it's no longer like
oh share this anymore it's more just
like i appreciate you thank you and i
have a bun i have like an ongoing of
like
probably like 200 dms of people who are
always floating to the top because
they're always hitting me up i'm just in
conversation it's like my lights like
brushing my teeth now just like
interacting with the people who [ __ ]
with me so it's just an everyday thing
any dax tattoos out there bro there's
like 10 000 10 000 plus dax tattoos
really yeah there's one stew just got
one on his face with a bunch of face
ones one of the dudes who just won a ps5
for my contest i opened up the dm
and in 2020 he sent me a picture of like
his dax tattoo here what the [ __ ]
there's ten thousand there's ten
thousand plus especially when i get like
tattoos like i don't want another sorry
or dear mom everything you did was worth
it like a bunch of people get those ones
what's the crazy is there like one that
was so crazy that you were like hey you
get shows forever just just hit me uh
like this face tattoo was crazy that is
a dope idea though to say like
but i don't want to promote people to
get dax face tattoos
yeah i think it was dope that he got one
that's my guy know well he's got your
face on his face no he's got like my
name tatted here and it's a fire but i
have a lot of people with like the i
have a joker tattoo right here a lot of
people have that one
um
but yeah i should start doing something
that's crazy that's dope
yeah but you also i don't want to i
guess i don't want to
you know
yeah promote face tattoos yeah it's like
you know you hey we i'd like it it's
cool yeah i like i like the most the
ones i like most is like when people get
my lyrics tatted mm-hmm that's dope
that's probably yeah because it means it
your lyrics kind of they put the little
like dash and like a dax beside it
what is uh what's next for you man man
continue to make an impact this year i
got some of the most impactful
songs of all time dropping with amazing
visuals so that's what's next just
continue to touch people with it do more
shows shake more hands kiss more babies
um
you know
start a family you know find a wife you
know you know just the life things
start a family find a wife is important
right um
what was what the girl who uh is the uh
inspiration for the cheated records what
what's she doing
um i don't talk to i don't know have you
heard like i mean i'm a certified i mean
i'm just saying you're like super
popping now so like i'm assuming like
she probably regrets [ __ ] you over
man and does she know that those songs
are about her
uh i mean yeah
uh you know obviously um it was a
definitely a crazy time but i i pray for
i don't i really don't know i don't stay
in contact with anyone i used to talk to
for people who go through that [ __ ] like
getting cheated on could be like if it
feels like when it happens the absolute
worst thing in the [ __ ] world that
could happen and especially because it's
like
you never hear it from the man's
perspective i think just now like even
we were talking about before but like
the different like podcasts of like men
talking about their gripes and things
that's new mm-hmm in the space for like
from the past till now it's always been
like women telling about these things
so i think like the reason that song
resonated so much because there's like
it was the first time a man was sort of
like he went through this and like
telling the story yeah yeah no that's
real and like it is the worst like when
you're going through that [ __ ] with
someone you you think you love it's like
the worst [ __ ] you could go through yeah
it feels like your life's gonna end like
you'll put it all on the [ __ ] line
it'll get you out of your character yeah
there's nothing like that will get get
somebody out of their character more
than that specific situation i feel
right just tired all just wanting to
sleep
yes sleep it off you'll be [ __ ]
depressed in bed all [ __ ] day
it's the worst dude for real yeah and
i've definitely been cheated on so i
definitely but like what would be some
advice you'd give to somebody who might
might have went through something like
that man i always say you know time
heals all wounds some wounds just take
longer than others it's really tough
write some goals work towards something
and have that thought in your mind that
you're gonna glow up on that person and
go [ __ ] another [ __ ] it helps right get
you know get it out do your thing
yeah you know i mean go ahead and you
know
you know
bust down a stranger real quick yeah you
know not too much of a stranger
obviously it's tough i mean [ __ ] yeah no
it's definitely tough man uh will there
be another album coming
uh i mean eventually i don't i don't i
have no plans but when i have a bunch of
stuff ready at all times i'm always
locked and loaded right right
i don't know it's just like it's like
i feel like when you make songs like i
make and you put all this effort into it
it's like it's very
uh
like if i drop another album it's
definitely going to be with a major
label because i refuse to put that much
effort with all these types of crazy
songs and it not gets somewhat makes
what it deserves
any other big collabs you just dropped
the record with snow recently right you
got fire yeah that was great too i was
so happy when that one came out because
that itself was a three year process as
well really that was a three year
process when did you guys shoot the
video recently uh it was december it was
like november okay okay but i remember i
first
saw snow like when i used to like my
first years here or first year here
when i came out here with that eight
month period um i went to some interview
and i interviewed on a show and then she
was the on the bigger interview after me
oh nice and then like i put her on my
story and then she like hit me back was
called she's lit
talking stayed in for three years and
then finally made a song yeah she's dope
and she's finally like i feel like
finally getting like uh the love she
deserves right the spanish [ __ ] is going
crazy crazy she's on fire for sure well
go follow my god dax stacks
is that is there a name for that is that
like like you've been doing that forever
for a while for a very long time sort of
do it now just to please the people
you know
but now i call it the
i like it yes sir boom appreciate you
pulling up man thank you man boom